with thousands of local government
positions being decided across south
korea from rural county officials to
mayors of big metropolitan cities this
will be a telling snapshot of which way
the country is leaning politically and
whether conservative yun sukyol's
presidency will be given a boost since
he won by the slimmest of margins of
less than one percent over his rival
i like his character and will continue
to support him
it remains to be seen if he will live up
to expectations but i think he'll carry
out state duties better than the
previous president
the liberal candidate defeated in the
presidential race lee jae-myung is
running again this time for one of seven
national assembly seats being contested
in by-elections seemingly asking voters
for a second chance
an incompetent can send people to hell
remember that fact i think holding
people accountable for the past that was
done in the presidential election
the vacant seat in incheon which is far
more blue-collar than neighboring seoul
is normally considered safe for the
liberal democratic party but lee has
been finding it unexpectedly tough
especially emerging from the pandemic
i hope this market can be revitalized so
that ordinary people can eat and have a
better life
the democrats need to reflect a little
more now i hope they don't lose their
original goals and do better
in these same elections four years ago
the democratic party scored a landslide
grabbing 14 of the 17 big city mayor and
provincial governor positions now racked
by infighting over controversial
policies they face much closer races
across the country
these elections will not just be a
verdict on the new president but also on
the man and his party that he defeated
rob mcbride al jazeera seoul